[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: So you
know what screams out,
"this app is slow?"
A spinner, especially
one that sits
around mocking the user
while the activity behind it
is trying to load some UI data.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and this
is one of the most annoying
UI patterns on Android.
And believe it or not, it's
actually really easy to fix.
See, it's 2015 now, and
most modern applications
drive the entirety
of their UI based
upon information they grab
from some server resource.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
Ping the server for updated
data, and once you get it,
update your UI to
reflect the changes.
Pretty simple, right?
The problem here
is in what the user
is seeing while they're waiting
for you to fetch the updated
information.
And sure, if user's
been using the app,
then chances are the screen is
already populated with data.
But when you're responding
to a gnarly context change
or are loading the app for
the first time in a while,
there's no data to
pre-populate your view,
so you have to default
to a spinner on top
of a blank screen.
Now, the fix here is
really straightforward.
Caching.
See, at some point
in the past, you've
actually grabbed a valid
block of UI information,
except on your first
load, of course.
But anyhow, although
the data is outdated,
your app can use that
information in these situations
where the fresh data
hasn't been fetched yet.
See, it works like this.
Upon a successful
fetch of some UI data,
serialize it to a
persistent storage
alongside some
timestamp so you know
how old the information is.
When you find yourself
in a cold boot situation,
you can use the existing UI
data to start drawing the screen
while also kicking
off your server
commands to grab the
freshest information.
Sure, you'll still
need to flag the user
and say what new information
is being fetched.
But at least they're looking
at a legitimate screen instead
of a blank UI with some
crummy spinner on it, right?
And that's really
pretty much it.
Cache your UI data so
that you can use it later
when you need to
wait for the server
to give you some updates.
Pretty straightforward,
actually.
Uh--
Oh!
By the way, it's
worth pointing out
that there's a right and a wrong
way to store this data to disk.
Firstly, you should be using
a binary serialization format
since they produce
smaller file sizes
and have faster performance
than human-readable formats
like JSON or XML.
Secondly, take the
time to figure out
the best way to cache this
information persistently.
Just storing it to
the serialized blob
is one way of doing this.
However, if your UI is dependent
on a lot of complicated queries
across that data,
unserializing that to load it
may not be the
best idea compared
to storing it in a SQLite
database, which could
be a much faster solution.
But really, any of
these options is
better than showing a blank
screen with some spinner on it.
Even if you're the
fastest app on the planet,
this will feel incredibly
slow to your users.
And user perception is
what it's all about, which
is why should check out the
rest of the "Android Performance
Patterns" videos.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ Community to ask other
questions as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]